this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus Medical Art library or nmaw
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you or someone you know may have been
diagnosed with type 1 diabetes this
video will help you understand what it
is and why it's important to keep it
under control
type 1 diabetes is a condition where
your pancreas makes little or no insulin
insulin is a chemical your body needs to
keep your blood sugar at a normal level
carbohydrates are substances your body
uses to make energy after you eat food
that contains carbohydrates it
eventually goes to your small intestine
in your small intestine the food is
broken down into single sugar molecules
called glucose the cells in your small
intestine soak up the sugars
which pass into your bloodstream
when the blood reaches your pancreas it
detects the high amount of sugar in your
blood
normally this causes your pancreas to
put insulin into your bloodstream the
insulin reduces the amount of sugar in
your blood to a healthy level how does
insulin do this
as the blood moves through your body the
insulin and sugar exit the bloodstream
into your tissues to reach your cells
most cells have structures on their
surfaces called insulin receptors when
insulin flows by it attaches to the
receptor
the insulin acts like a key in a lock to
open up the cell
so the sugar can get inside
now your cell can use the sugar to make
the energy it needs to work properly and
your blood sugar level drops back to its
normal range
if you have type 1 diabetes your
pancreas loses its ability to make
enough or any insulin
this can result in high blood sugar
levels and other complications
in type 1 diabetes
your immune system attacks some cells in
your pancreas by mistake
as a result your pancreas makes little
or no insulin
without insulin sugar cannot get into
your cells without sugar your cells
don't have energy
and since the sugar is locked out of
your cells it builds up to a high level
in your bloodstream this is a condition
called hyperglycemia which can lead to
serious complications
if you have questions about type 1
diabetes or any medications you have
been prescribed speak with your doctor
it is important to take your medications
as directed by your doctor tell him or
her about any side effects you have